from screen junk studios in the Heart of
Los Angeles this is screen junkies drunk
movie fights now your host Andy sigor
we're going to do the
shot hello everybody Welcome to drunk
movie fights this is the third drunk
movie fights meaning the winner today
goes on to fight Ken napso and Alicia
Malone in the finals for the first ever
drunk movie fights Championship we've
got some great fights today including
people um including questions about who
should be the new liveaction genie in
Aladdin what villain should Fight the
Power Rangers why is my chair so squeaky
and a big blind fight so much so there's
a lot to get to tonight if you would
like to join in on the conversation live
on Twitter go to Hash movie fights live
let's meet our Fighters first he's
normally the host of the show my Nemesis
when I'm on that side of the table uh
but here he's here today to fight with
uh is that that Hard Lemonade again I
got smear up I got Vodka I got apple
juice get messy it's Andy s ladies and
gentlemen I want to just can we all do a
shot to start this show yeah sure Shar
bottom up get shitfaced we're going to
curse to
Uber what was that bu I got to say now
fans you're either a fan of this kind of
show you're not but now you know in
advance to tune out or to stay tuned
yeah and if you're if you're watching
this on your phone live pull
over oh okay second she's one of the
newer screen junkies but already a
season drinker cuz I guess you're from
New York right is that correct I'm from
New York and I've been a drinker for
many years thank you I have a PhD and
drunk ladies and gentlemen Roth cornette
hello I'm so excited to be here with my
favorites nice kept in the family today
yeah yeah yeah kind of it's almost as
incestuous as my family
reunions whoa W I'm already drunk okay
are you doing a he's from the south
transition yeah exactly exactly uh third
our Winter Soldier and soon to be are we
allowed to say though yes he is now okay
soon to be Rick Grimes for the screen
junkies roasts uh our friend Emmy Award
nominated along with this gentleman Joe
star I'm very excited to do this and uh
drink with Roth and Andy with his
sorority
drinks I I kind of call like Andy has to
drink one of those to every shot Joe and
I do it's Shenanigans a little bit no no
because there's so much sugar in that
he's going he going he's going to lose a
leg before he loses his promise you I
get drunk off two of these I don't know
how it works he's so dainty be great I'm
not
but and our fact Checker today is uh Mr
Spencer Gilbert can we call that the
Spencer camam the Spenny cam spinny Cam
and sitting next to him is on the fan
cam is Danny petrusa welcome Danny you
pelts so you're voting for
Trump all right all right all right all
right I mean as much as I'd love to talk
trash here let's just get to this ladies
and gentlemen I want to get us as drunk
as possible um you a shot
what ready calm down Leaving Las
Vegas okay a quick reminder of the rules
all scoring is based on the facts
presented passion and creativity
ultimately it depends on what I liked
but we're not going to that so uh let's
get to round one shall we now let's do
this this is where
we oh I
forgot
the only time
we oh they're drunk like that a good
that was a good intro yeah that was
awesome I should have heard I wish I had
the light for to hear what they were
saying okay so Disney has just announced
they're moving forward with the live
action Aladdin with guy Richie
directing that's not the question so uh
screen junkie Super Fan Jonathan pek
wants to know who should play the genie
and we're going to start with Andy I'm
going with an interesting choice I'm
going with walking Phoenix now here's
why walking Phoenix is mysterious he's a
dark tortured soul I want to see a new
take on this Genie I don't want to see
what we've already seen before you can't
beat you can't beat the original you
just can't and walking Phoenix is going
to bring something we've never seen
before it's like that Heath Ledger Joker
moment you're like what but then you're
kind of like okay I kind of want to see
that and I don't I dare any of you in
this panel to say otherwise
okay I I say otherwise I say that when
we examine the evidence that we will
find that there is only one reasonable
choice to take part as the genina to
take on this iconic role in this movie
and that is 100% sir Dwayne The Rock
Johnson he is if we really think about
it the genie the rock of all people in
the world he wants you to have your
wishes come true he's trying to make it
happen for you just with his very look
at that face his undeniable palpable
charm and energy he is an action hero
this is a guy Richie movie he is larger
than life the rock is the man okay Joe
your take Jonathan pek this was a great
question I want to thank you for asking
he doesn't vote on who wins I just want
to apologize to him for these two shitty
answers that have let off the show
there's only
one uh answer for who should play the
new Genie and it is another funny
improviser likable guy that does a lot
of characters and that's Bill hater he's
going to be a great Genie sometimes the
obvious choice is the best
choice that's all we're
getting I just said like four more
sentences than both of them it's a lot
of
buildup rebuttal I guess hater is is an
interesting choice but how are you not
going to compare him to Robin Williams
the entire I compare him to Robin
Williams
did you see Aladdin 2 cast linetta
trying to be cetta is no hater sir watch
it and I don't want another dark
tortured Soul playing the genie cuz I
want to keep this Genie around thank you
very much I've already had a few to
drink also what does that mean oh cuz
he's going to kill himself that's really
also also also I'm sorry but you want
another like w Phoenix Heath like ke
heith Ledger Joker moment the next HEI
Ledger Joker moment we got was Jared
Leto so that's that's a terrible
comparison to want to make Bill hater
does characters he's fun Disney is going
to want to keep this movie in step with
Aladdin they're not going to want the
rock that's weird um at most Rock can
play songs on acoustic guitar they're
going to want a funny guy that does
Impressions and that's Bill oh sir The
Rock has spent his entire career playing
multiple characters that's what he did a
as a wrestler he is born for theatrics
number one and talk about a naturally
melodious voice if we are going a
musical Direction in this movie there is
an actual video called The Rock sings
better than Justin Bieber why he is a
beautiful singer he has a lovely singing
voice if we're going musical but if
we're not which we're probably not
because this is a guy Richie movie who
is a better Action Hero today sir than
the rock who do you want in your life
granting your wishes the rock the genie
is not an action hero though he's the
genie he's big blue cloud it's a guy
Richie movie you don't think there's
going to be action not magic lamp The
Rock played two characters in his
wrestling career a completely unlikable
boring baby face and then an evil guy in
an expensive shirt that made uh Chinese
food puns about your genitals those are
his two wrestling characters fight me on
that if you want Ro can't do voices like
even when he's doing Moana which I'm
excited for and I love the rock he's
still playing The Rock like I don't see
the range you need from a The Rock to
play the genie so I right there that's
my struggle it's I think it's a better
call than Bill hater because I still
stand by the fact as good as Bill hater
is you can't put someone in the same
style to do the same thing Robin
Williams did okay final arguments
already wow final arguments on this one
I will say this that bill hater even in
the image that was used of him looked
bored and disinterested in playing the
genie this is not the person that needs
to play the genie at all walking Phoenix
I'm sorry he's a tremendous actor but he
has no interest in these kinds of films
that i' say he would do it certainly
doesn't have the charm or Charisma or
magnetism that would capture the genie
something so iconic that Robin Williams
himself delivered unto us the only
person really unto us now we're getting
biblical yes the only person who has the
power to bring that lightning bolt of
magic is in fact the Rockstar so you're
asking him to do the same lightning bolt
of magic again that's the problem here I
want to do something new and I'm not
saying he's got to be dramatic and Jared
Leo poor I think uh uh walking vs is a
fantastic actor with amazing and can
pull off anything he was hilarious I've
heard enough Shut up I didn't get a
final argument you just no that's fine
I'm the only one that said words but
that's fine because even though of the
three my of these three choices myself I
think Bill hater would be the best your
argument was you you started drinking
too early so um then it comes down to
the Rock and Walken Phoenix and The Rock
does have the physical the physical the
pose and the body that would look great
on screen painted blue and he has Charis
but then you lost me when you said he's
played multiple characters he's played
people with different names but they're
all ultimately The Rock he's not the
perfect character for this role holy
[__] is Mark going to give me the point
and even though even though I really
don't want to see walking Phoenix as the
genie I was literally writing down when
you said dark and tortured I was writing
down Heath Ledger versus Jack Nicholson
Joker and then you said it because I
thought that's what I thought when I saw
Heath Ledger's first picture so yes
unlike you I am so the point goes to
Andy all right I I was going to say that
was a quick round but I like that I like
that you disqualified Ross argument
using my argument for Bill you do the
whole show like that this will be a very
quick episode we won't get too drunk
perf no no and Draco I think I have some
things that could slow this down a bit
because I'm sorry I'm a little hyper I
only did two lines before I
got Oh I thought you said c i I want to
bring up two things one is that you can
follow along and tweet me at # movie
fights live to tweets read live on the
air like this one from Rob prog bet you
anything Kevin Hart will play the genie
which is probably what we're going to
end up with and also I want to introduce
some special Drink Along rules uh oh I
forgot all about these we have a few
things that I'm going to need your guys'
help to keep track of that will make uh
some people drink some more uh anytime
Andy burps we take a drink oh good one
anytime Roth quote gets New York we take
a drink I'm not sure exactly what that
means does a pigeon steal your hot dog I
don't know what New York means anytime
Joe Blanks on an actor or a movie we
drink uh anytime Mark says Andy's right
this is tough or I guess just this is
tough we take a drink anytime jte [__]
up uh we we just take a drink uh if the
fan pole chooses someone different from
Mark The Winner Takes a shot uh and uh
and anytime uh Andy argues with the
judge we we drink as well so that should
be the extra Drink Along rules that
should get us nice and soft before we go
home today did we do any of those right
now no I think we're good so far they
have to take a shot right because they
lost so the fan pole actually went with
Bill haer on that one Joe waen lost the
fan pole 14% to 47% so it says The
Winner Takes a shot I'm not shot I guess
you're the winner Andy you're the big
winner good Roes going New York mean
that Roth announces that she publicly
supports Spider-Man I do publicly
support Spider-Man we with you
Spider-Man all the way I have to say I
thought that bill hater was going to be
the really hard one to fight because
he's so amazing oh
boy somebody's wife is holding their
hair back
tonight Al The Rock does great voices
okay so I I'll do my best to keep track
of these but uh Andy you are in the lead
let's do this yeah more last all righty
question two I hit my notes
today whether you like the first trailer
or not the Power Rangers MO movie is on
its way so what we want to know is what
movie villain ideally should Fight the
Power Rangers and this time we're going
to start with the lovely Miss Roth okay
so I have chosen Skynet to Fight the
Power Rangers and here's why this is why
I think this works it is basically a
battle between technology and Magic but
not only that stage one of Skynet going
against the Power Rangers involves them
taking over their beloved allies in
battle the Zords themselves and then
after that the Zords have to battle
themselves because they do have a soul
if you're reading the text very
accurately there's a soul connection
between the Rangers and the Zords
everyone Dr drink drink
mofo oh she just got on the New York
drink
again oh that's
fair that that is a fair point that is
very accurate anyway the point of this
is that it gives you a fun but Dynamic
Rich textured look at the Rangers and at
the end of the day you have the Zords
taking back their autonomy to reconnect
with their soul connected Rangers which
again it's in the text if you really are
looking very closely and Skynet has
built a false Megazord to fight the
actual Zord giant robots fighting
boom okay I didn't understand a word of
that um the only one Mr star how do you
understand that
Skynet so you want the Power Rangers to
just fight big [__] robots and there
is not a bigger [__] robot than
Unicron from Transformers of the movie
the giant planet-sized planet eating
robot voiced by Orson Wells this thing
is horrifying uh the opening of
Transformers in the movie is intensely
scary whether you're a little kid or a
grown man uh who still loves cartoons
like I do uh it's this menacing score by
Vince D Cola who did the synth score for
like Rocky and a bunch of awesome stuff
and he just descends on this civilian
planet people are running for their
lives and they're trying to escape the
planet he consumes the whole thing this
is a cool villain for the Power Rangers
because not only is he a giant robot but
you have to get inside of him to beat
him and once you're inside there's all
sorts of nasis you have to fight so like
the Zords fight the planet the Power
Rangers go inside there's all sorts of
stuff to do and he's voiced by Orson
Wells and that's just pretty cool
Unicron all righty Mr Sor look I'm going
to say something maybe unpopular here I
don't want to see another Power Rangers
movie I don't care if I'm going to see
it I want to go full on cheese so why
not put the most cheesiest perfect
villain yet apocalypse from X-Men
apocalypse look at this fool he'll fit
right in he looks like he's from the
freaking movie already and the one cool
thing he can do is he can decapitate
people with sand I'd watch that again
especially if it's the Power Rangers
getting decapitated so it's no brainer
PL now all right so I'm going to start
in because I now we all said it you
Unicron is just going to turn into some
space fart like Green Lantern space f
it's going to be a sky beam no matter
how you handle it's too big and you do
that live action and the Power Rangers
going against this big entity it's not
going to be the threat you think it's
going to be no it's going to be a giant
robot they hav't to make a giant
robot be
a apocalypse I don't know if you watched
your own honest trailer Andy signore but
he never uses disintegrating sand we
pointed it out he did it once oh he did
it oh he did it once heads once he's so
dumb and in this opportunity you could
do it more times it's not even cheesy
fun at least Unicron is like is just a
big cheesy 80s robot badass if you want
chees easier see that rber face plus
Skynet is an app yeah that you didn't
even say Terminator we are the
Terminator
you are we going get are we going to get
the stupid like uh like the robots are
going to have an internal battle with
themselves and then they're going to go
to a retreat and they're going to
reconnect with the Rangers with like
bongo drums and a [__] campire that
sounds so boring so boring you want to
talk about boring possibly the most
boring villain to be seen on screen in
The Last 5 Years is freaking yours that
could not be a more boring movie he
couldn't even spice up the movie that he
wasn't and you want to give him another
one how the hell does that make any
sense because this movie doesn't deserve
a good vill and it doesn't even deserve
to be made who cares the crap it
deserves the only movie in which one of
the most talented actors of our time was
Ill not effective is this movie Oscar
Isaac was only bad in this movie of all
the movies he's ever been in by the way
he was in Sucker Punch to you he was yes
to you unicorn was already used so
effectively and talk about not cheesy
all the
1986 Transformers movie is the furthest
thing from cheesy sir that character has
already been used brilliantly in a movie
that is the best iteration of the
Transformers that we have ever seen and
should not be bastardized at all in this
power wouldn't it turn into a space fart
Skybeam space fart it's going to be a
space fart Skybeam it's going to be an
app and a purple raisin I don't want to
see those things on screen ever again
Califoria record sounds like the most
villain out of these into a big [__]
robot that's
awesome mid
like the power 100% depend on their
Zords and what can Skynet control
machines Skynet could take over the very
thing that that's so boring
though she's talking with her hands like
a New Yorker okay she's literally eating
a bagel you Skynet proved Skynet Pro I
mean Genesis Terminator Genesis proved
how boring Skynet is
I want to I want to see the T1000 I want
to see Terminators they didn't even give
us any of those by the way Sky having
Skynet means inherently that you're
going to have t1000s and you're going to
have terminates and you're going to have
everything that's already associated
with Skynet you are going to have the
machines involved and not only that but
Skynet can take over the machine they're
going to possess the swords look nothing
brings nothing brings a caliber of
Menace like Unicron
does he's a he's a classic it's a giant
planet that [__] eats everything like
that's you don't get scarier than that
there's only one thing that can destroy
it the Power Rangers don't have it how
can they beat Unicron inside unicorn
there's a giant room where he just picks
up smaller things and people from the
planet and just drops them into lava I
don't know what it does it's just
terrifying okay we're beginning I'm
beginning to hear the same arguments
over and over again everybody gets one
more shot to defeat the other person and
then we'll continue look Joe's is
just I not it was cool in the movie it
was cool in the anime movie not going to
get conveyed the same way in a
liveaction film my character apocalypse
he had the coolest death I think that
sand scene actually was pretty cool
aledi wasn't great that's why I'm
putting him in this because I don't
think this movie is going to be very
great it looks like The Breakfast Club
meets crap anyway uh but why not put
something that makes sense in there and
and and let's amp it up and actually
give us the apocalypse we want in the
cheesy Power Ranger suit that we we're
used to I think that's kind of a fun
movie for kids and for idiots nothing
could bleed life out of this movie
faster than adding apocalypse which they
managed to make the most boring villain
in the last 10 years nothing could have
been a worse Choice Andy but you're my
boss it was great um and as far as
you're concern I'm not your boss today
well then nothing could have been
wor nothing could have been a worse
choice to make this movie less
interesting than it already was as far
as yours goes first of all you just said
it yourself there's no movie in there
because they can't possibly fight him he
is unbeatable besides the character's
already been used perfectly my character
which is Skynet is beatable but it's
very hard to beat and Skynet with the
machines and with the t1000s and taking
control of the zorts using the very
thing that they use to win their battles
is turning them against themselves that
is dynamic that is storytelling at the
end mark this's my final thought okay
Andy's argument was 90% fart
noises and Roth's argument was that my
idea is too good that's ridiculous she
gave she just keeps repeating the thing
about robots getting possessed and then
they find themselves apocalypse is just
boring Unicron fits with Power Rangers
because in other iterations of the
Transformers he's appeared as like a
smaller being and then he grows and what
is more Power Rangers than make my
Monster Grow they fight him as Power
Rangers they fight him with Zords when
he gets bigger and then they do a big
cheesy Rock number to beat Unicron with
because Power Rangers is cheesy and the
80s Transformers as much as I love them
you had your final thought Andy I love
you but you had your final
thought I've I've he's let me talk over
a few times and the internet has let me
know when that happens so being
respectful and raising my hand
apocalypse grows my brother remember
that scene when it was in the hand in a
dream it was in a dream [__] you I've
heard enough I've heard enough I've
heard enough okay uh some quick facts uh
on this one before you make your ruling
Oscar Isaac was in Sucker Punch sadly
enough he got dental insurance so Skynet
isn't an appp technically Genesis was
the app uh and not a cat at all
helpfully points out to Joe isn't Orson
Wells
dead so it's isn't Tupac de yet he's a
[__]
hologram 201 the critics selling fish
sticks Tupac and Elvis have released
more albums posim usly than when they
were alive yeah they got some b-roll at
Unicron all right okay well first of all
I'm going eliminate the bottom person on
this one unfortunately Roth it was
you all I see in a Power Rangers movie
with Skynet is the old dial uping
Ding and it just seems very ephemeral if
if like Neil leut was doing the Power
Rangers movie you would have won but as
a big this is a fake Power Rangers movie
maybe NE is that would be weird so weird
and um the Unicron
thing I I've never seen that movie I
know the song from Boogie Nights right
that's song he sings um from the visual
we saw Unicron was a planet like the
Death Star right and he turns into a
giant gatron yeah he turns into
Galvatron he just turns into a bigger
Unicron no CU G is Megatron gatron is
EXC burped very
burped oh you got to stop burping um so
yeah it's a death star that turns into a
big robot okay that could have been a
little clearer if I had know if that was
a little clearer for the neophytes in
the Transformers Animated World
um you
know apocalypse yes that
costume and I think his powers were what
does the script need to propel us to the
next scene powers and decapitating sand
and decapitating
sand but
learning that making an making an Oscar
nominated actor of that caliber wear
basically what looks like a giant blue
vibrator
and make him earn any any any whatever
Oscar ISAC gets paid for his next 10
movies is not enough because he did that
with such
sincerity I don't believe I'm saying
this but um I'm going with apocalypse oh
[__] the world's most sincere vibrator
wins it now luckily the fan pole agrees
with uh that pick so no one needs to
take a shot unless you want to yes I'll
take a I'll take a drink
though okay do we have any other facts
that we need checks no no clean around
otherwise clean around oh here's a
depressing
question as if those to work should uh
should I give the person's handle who
gave us this question now that I've
insulted them or should I not at danger
land 17 it's not about you it's about
the fact that this is real uh the
question is the Emoji movie is in
development so John mass at danger land
17 asked us what non non-game smartphone
app not including Skynet or feature
would make the best film and this time
we start with
Joe so I think the mistake that uh all
these app movies are going to make cuz
they're going to make themid Dr that's a
drink it's a tactic now sh I no are we
all a drink
M so they're going to make all these
movies for kids Angry Birds the Emoji
Movie is going to be for kids I think
you need to change that up I think you
need to make a sexy dark Thriller about
the Postmates app
and for those listening at home I got a
sole Applause break from the other side
of
the they're just swatting it a fly
that's not Applause ah Postmates a
little man that wears a cape and farts
Stars I guess uh and stole et's bike
delivers you anything you want that seat
looks like it's two Knuckles deep Jesus
Mark and Draco folks what happens
when a man named I don't know
Danny he's doing Postmates to pay his
way through college what happens when
the same person mysteriously starts
ordering Postmates from Danny just requ
he's always having to go to the same
mysterious weird person's apartment
they're kind of turned on by him he's
kind of turned on by them where's this
going but don't trust them they might be
a murderer they might not they might
just be you know kind of sexy mysterious
keeps having to bring him postmate stuff
is he delivering them the things that
he's going to use to maybe murder him at
the end of the movie is postmate sort of
a great Gone Girl sort of flick I think
it is Postmates the weird creepy
Thriller that comes on HBO at 2 a.m.
brought to you by the fine folks at Blum
House my turn oh I'm sorry yes Andy I
was so into the Postmates movie I was
just like visualizing it sorry goe all
right I'm going Max Landis I'm literally
am prepping this on the spot I'm going
to I'm going to go see how how he does
this see if I can just do it I'm going
this is all improvisation right ready
Yelp the movie okay that's the only
thing I
knew all right so here's what I'm
thinking right we're in because I I want
to pitch my app my app needs to approve
this movie right all these apps are
going to need to approve these movies
you're not going to be do it otherwise
so I want to go inside of of Yelp all
those critics those are little
characters like Wreck-It Ralph style
right and they're all thriving to get
their reviews heard and get these these
these restaurants raided right so
they're all got to get their their start
and save some of these restaurants now
they they have a quota to fill and they
got to be mean to some of these
restaurants turns out there is a
conspiracy as some restaurants find but
there's one restaurant there's one
restaurant he's just they're they have
kids in college they got to they're just
trying to get their kids out and get the
world done they're just they're out of
money the banks on them hard and one
loan Yelp reviewer has got to do what he
can do to to Rally Yelp together from
the inside out to turn this around and
get the the the the the real life people
to come to this restaurant this is going
to be an Underdog Story to prove the
worth of Yelp and you're going to get
this amazing meet these little
characters the little troll guy the
little the little taco guy oh everybody
heal care profile all the characters
there you want is there you got you got
you got so
whatever a second
chance anyway they're they're all inside
and they all got a make a difference and
they got to fight for this restaurant
they got to save it save the business
they got to save it from the bank and
they can do it Yelp Yelp Yelp
Yelp the movie
wow follow that one I have no idea how
that movie works like is the restaurant
also I'll explain more but I'm allowing
you to go rob all right so I'm doing bit
Emoji the movie here's a movie that we
never thought was going to make any
sense you just drew a circle on your
card it was really
intimidating ladies and gentlemen I have
a circle that's the worst bitemoji the
movie a movie that we thought would
never make sense at all yall know
bitemoji Lego Movie until it made the
most sense ever you go inside the bit
Emoji this is the scariest thing I've
ever driven you go inside the world of
bitemoji and this is how this movie
makes me feel
emojis
people expressing the movie
already was longer than the opening of
touch and evil to get on that
car is this a
knockout graphic ready yet no got get
that graphic ready she's on the ropes do
we have do we have the shy cam ready all
right guys okay you got this okay you
got this two emojis the two emojis
representing two people in the real
world that are flirting with each other
using their B emojis which is something
that I have seen happen with people we
know
and so these two bit emojis are
representing their people they are the
avatars they're in the bitemoji world
and they're going through the different
Realms of bitmoji like the Halloween
Halloween holiday realm just like if you
think if you could marry um Nightmare
Before Christmas Lego Movie and Wreck-It
Ralph it's going through all of these
different Realms and coming out and the
is the PO is the is the smiling poo a
bit Emoji yeah this that's an emoji the
villain of the piece is frowny face
emoji which is one of the realms and
frowny face bit Emoji separates them
into sleepy time bit Emoji which is
another realm so he's the Bill Cosby
Emoji yeah
Bill not drunk enough yet for rape jokes
um
so was there a ceiling for
that
wow that count being New York yeah yeah
how go New York cuz no one else thinks
in terms of I've heard enough rape
jokes
okay okay wow brownie face emoji is the
villain puts them in sleepy time vmoji
realm traps in there so that he's
sending negative messages to the two
humans they have to fight frowny face B
emoji and come out of the sleeping realm
in order to reignite the romance between
the humans outside Boom the end okay
okay guys first of all here's a Yelp
review for you Andy the only thing worse
than improv is when people announce that
they're about to do it Jesus you just
did it that was like then you never talk
Joe no I have literally never spoken
offended me
Joe R you you were you're the scariest
kind of movie executive who just says
the names of things we all like and then
says it's like that uh you basically
just described inside out too Inside Out
is already handling this emotion stuff
they already taught us that sadness is a
valid emotion so sadness should not be a
bad guy in a movie absolutely not you
talk Andy do you agree inside out
already covered this stuff am I right I
mean who wants to watch the bit emojis
they're the most annoying trend on
Facebook I've ever seen in my life I
don't the only thing I want to watch
less than bit emojis is a movie about
Yelp where people who think that their
own dumb opinions here's what I got to
say are meaningful and useful well
here's the problem Joe as cute as your
Postmates Thriller was it was very cute
I'll give you that it was very cute
there is no way Postmates is going to
put together a thriller that shows that
Postmates makes crazy people deliver to
you it's just not feasible we now we can
be as drunk as we want but you can't get
over the fact that Postmates is never
going to Green l a movie about murderous
delivery boys like that's just goes
against the business model when you're
out of creative gas your arguments
immediately go to what some [__]
executive would argue in a room my
Postmates movie is going to win Oscars
Ben Affleck's probably going to be in it
cuz he did gong girl and he sure was
great Henry Cav's going to be in it Mark
Mark and Draco he's the Del sounds like
a second rate 50 Shades it's going to be
terrible and uh Yelp come on there's so
much to be built here this is something
this is going to BU take Yelp to that
next Lev what are people going to do in
the Yelp movie they're just going to
write reviews your movie is just a
series of people it did I tell you who's
directing it Mr Char Charlie
Kaufman this is I mean Arisa Being John
malovich we going to into the mind of Y
because there's
nothing okay hold on hold on because
because he threw in a director that
wasn't in his initial argument I'm going
to allow you both real quick to think of
a direct how much how much credit is he
going to bring to this movie okay my
directors are Miller and Lord who did
the Lego
mov you are cre creatively bankrupt oh
my God [__] you seriously so hard today
Joe Andor also get to New York New
York oh man and as far as Charlie
Kaufman goes I do not think that Yelp
wants puppet conolingus to sell their
freaking app I'm sorry I'm who isn't
there that's my drag name now anomala
was one of my favorite
movies and I say yes to all the
conolingus especially the public
canalingus but we're talking that's very
New York as well God damn it you want
director drinking but your argument was
I one of the directors we got time for
this this movie wasn't going to get made
cuz the app wouldn't approve it the app
is definitely not going to approve that
was my question my question was who is
the director Mr star please this is an
erotic Thriller and I want someone to go
back to their erotic Thriller Roots
which I think we all want them to do and
that's the wichowski sisters bound is a
[__] sexy 2 a.m. movie no and
that's what this Postmates movie is you
should have gone the spirit of bound no
I should have gone wichowski sisters I
was thinking you were going Adrien line
myself
yeah no going full bound who did single
white female that was good too uh Barb
schroer yeah that's right okay all right
final arguments guys final thoughts
we'll start we go back this we'll start
with Joe and come back this way I want
something different we we've we've found
Angry Birds bombed this [__] Emoji
Movie is going to bomb let's stop aiming
things at kids let's aim things to
lonely adults at 2: a.m. cuz they're the
ones that are going to spend the money
to go to the theater to watch this on
HBO GO it's going to have
legs Postmates the sexy movie by the
wichowski sisters okay you just said
that these movies are going to bomb but
your movie is designed to be on HBO at 2
in the morning so how is that a
connected argument longm sucess no
that's short-term nothing do you know
how popular things are now on streaming
and H your argument Joe if your argument
is about the viability financially of
the movie the one movie on this table
whether you think it's creatively
bankrupt or not so is Hollywood and the
one movie that is financially viable and
could hit the four quadrants not just
kids is my movie and that is the only
one your movie doesn't even make sense
because how does the restaurant even get
involved in the thing it's inside of
the your restaurant
is absolutely not they're traveling
through the different bit bitmoji Realms
just like we saw in Wreck-It Ralph just
like we saw in The Lego Movie how is
mine not doing that too your movie is
literally inside out your movie sounds
like the most boring white person movie
that's just like you know the coffee
here is pretty subpar like that's your
movie oh my God I don't want to watch
that for an hour and a half no no no
mine has mystery in it okay and boo
final thoughts mine mine is a little
Inside Out mine's got the you got you're
getting your characters inside this
review every critic is a character and
you're going to ample offly those
critics and those those foods to be
amazing characters it's going to be
Pixar level stuff characters yes I said
there could be a taco whatever but I'm
saying inside so you are advocating
judging these things yeah the the how
very Trump I told you it's a little bit
of a conspiracy distracting me this is
anyway you're distracting me and that's
a good tactic CU I'm drunk but here's my
pitch mark I heard your pict inside of Y
don't turn your back on me it's wck
Ralph inside amazing critics enough
enough enough enough before we go to
Spencer I forgot to thank uh in round
one the question about Aladdin came from
at jpack 1098 sorry I didn't give you
credit where credit
was and now to the Spencer cam so yeah
lots of people recommending Tinder the
movie I would counter with that is what
porn is called and Joe your statement
that Angry Birds was a flop uh that made
sadly $347 million on a $73 million
budget I meant to say that people love
their Angry Birds did you Andy Andy also
said uh Amala when I think he meant an
Amala an
combine amaly
and the most depressing quirky movie of
all time okay this one actually this is
a horse race we got going on here um the
your movie when you first started
talking about it Joe made me think it
was like getting one going porny like
Danny does Postmates or something no
classy and then then it became a
combination of Fatal Attraction meets
You've Got Mail which is kind of
interesting then wowski sisters going
back to bound truly a really really
great movie um the bitemoji movie I
didn't know what a bit Emoji was until
today thanks to your lovely illustration
and um yours kind of sounds like like a
really depressed singles bar version of
Tron meets The
Matrix that sounds better amazing I did
I did like the fact that you had Mr
upset tummy what was the villain's name
face oh sorry frowny faceemoji was an
unreliable tummy guys a go was an
unreliable narrator I like that that was
very hitchcockian but then when you went
with Lorden Miller it was like oh we
have a Gothic movie based on a quirky
thing from the 30s let's get Tim Burton
it was just so on the nose that I
already know what that movie looks like
and I kind of don't want to see it um
your movie when the way you started
before you got drunker at the very
beginning of your argument I was really
impressed because I was thinking this
sounds like Roberts zc' Used Cars it is
or DC cab yeah it is and it actually
sounds like a legitimate real movie and
then you kept
talking and then I thought oh my God
Nancy Myers is going to direct this and
it's going to be rich white ladies in
pasmina going to West but then you said
Charlie
Kaufman
so but he said but he just said a name
it doesn't fit yes but but but I know I
know I know you direct this I would not
direct that ever did you hear he would
never direct this isn't about reality
folks this is about this is about the
arguments I'm using your own rules back
on you um but before I deliver my final
my final ruling let's uh let's go over
to the couch and ask our audience fan
member Danny which one what do you think
of these three
movies they're terrible I think I've
pitched to you
before okay terrible well did the
audience vote at home they did uh that
there's a lot of comments along the
lines of what Danny was saying which is
what the hell are you guys talking about
okay well that doesn't help well dogs
and cats are friends we have an clown
running for president and I can't
believe I'm doing this but for the third
time in a row holy [__] I'm going with
Andy wow YouTube is going to hate this
episode a blowout and I'm not that drunk
these wow wow well this should make
things interesting because the fans
voted for Postmates the Thriller uh
which means Andy needs to take a shot no
a shot or I do a shot I believe he got
to take a shot need anymore I'm
there
oh
boy and the table had a shot as
well all
right just lick it off do your best do
your not I'm
not okay all right round four you a
paper towel for oh at some point sorry I
got VOD call over my desk that sounds
like a euphemism Jo heard me say that a
lot I have that was my first interview
here and by vodka you didn't mean vodka
and desk definitely wasn't a desk no no
that's in my Postmates
movie oh so so it's a trigger warning
movie thank you for bringing me this
peanut brittle I kind of like the Tinder
movie I just do another train wow okay
that should have been my argument a porn
who we could just oh we could make a
porn no that would be I think next time
the rule needs to be next time Roth uses
a tense incorrectly what we we just make
some porn
how is porn an incorrect tense it's the
thing it's not even a tense it's the
thing that is your porn not might might
be tense but my porn is very
tense incredibly tense actually kind of
sad relaxing that's what it's supposed
to do well that's why I'm surpris after
the movie okay oh my God this is kening
wildly out of control I feel like suly
um I that should be a
drink to that
except I don't know how this one's going
to end yeah that's also New York yeah
York you that's Mark getting New
York wasn't New York the name of one of
those hookers on the the Flav of flave
show I think so I love New York I love
New York yeah and I'm sure she actually
wasn't a prostitute I'm that was my own
opinion I'm not speaking for define
media she was a lovely woman if she's
still alive um round four round four
wait test pattern the American flag goes
up I'm never com enjoy my final
appearance today ladies and
[Laughter]
gentlemen why do we have a tray with
penil on it bur why' you call it out I
burped so you have to drink when you
burp hang on we all do where's the why
this is just on the ground and I want
answers okay all right enough enough
Shenanigans let's get back to the
serious answer me what the [__] is this
it's performance
art okay
round four is the blind fight there are
three cups a traditional actor I think
we should get a six blind fight ready to
go just in case this goes too
quick like no a tradition a traditional
actor a non-traditional actor all right
and a title okay you will each draw one
from each cup and then pitch me the
movie and we'll be starting with Andy
who's deciding who's traditional or not
well the white patriarchy of course
okay I usually make this list and this
is the first time I've been on the
receiving end of it so this is fun okay
traditional I don't know what we mean by
traditional I'm someone who hold green
letter a movie wait until everybody has
them all it's your traditional a white
male Rock oh or the rock okay or the
rock how's this for New York don't not
yet
no that's very Chris Pratt that's he's
like Montana isn't he
my movie is the [__]
best okay D do we want to uh how do we
want to do Spencer I'm going to get your
opinion on this should we have the Mee
announce all what three they have and
then go this or before each question I
would give them an opportunity I think
Joe sounds pretty confident about his
maybe he should just go pitch okay we're
just going to start we're going to start
with wait we're starting with Andy this
time okay ready my title is called oh
sorry guys mine's a
romantic com romantic dramedy
okay Peter
Dinklage is a producer works at a news
station he's the nadition he just trying
to make he's just trying to be you know
a real hero there want's to be the big
man I didn't mean
that see that it's the chair that makes
people say stuff it's not me Peter
Dinklage is just a producer trying to
find his way and just get on top but his
his his boss played is a is a real b
word and it's played by Nancy Grace okay
remember you know all Nancy Grace and
she's playing a character similar to
herself where she's a very polarizing uh
polarizing Talent figure and Peter
Dinklage day after day has to Wrangle
her in but you know what as much as they
hate each other there's a secret love
brewing and they got a Peter's got to
figure out how to get this woman to fall
for him and just be nicer in general
yeah the film is called time after
slime he's going to find that time she's
always called slime because she just
will report any grub that comes through
the office and the the hotline the
hotline the Nancy Grace phone has it
work was that a
houp so this this is one of those movies
that really just just will make you
smile and it's called time after
slime yeah wow that was awesome yeah why
is Nancy graceon there let's move
forward my movie out a cup my
movie that's how everything gets made in
this town how long have you lived
here my movie is the actual app movie
that we wanted to see but we didn't in
the last round which is called swipe
right for murder also Roth has not been
drinking I thr that
out I'm really drunk I'm not
all right what's it called swipe right
for murder swipe she's revealing the
title already she's not very confident
then sorry swipe right for murder this
is directed by David Fisher and it stars
Jessica
Chastain as a hard-nosed detective going
after a serial killer who was using the
app Tinder to stalk and find victims and
he is going and he is finding the most
unlikely she is going and finding the
most unlikely victim oh I thought we
were getting into like crying game area
for a minute there but we don't know
you're just drunk we don't know okay we
might be going there um to find the most
unlikely murderer who's finding the I
don't know what I'm saying Anymore
Michael B Jordan plays her new partner
who is ill
equipped I don't know what I'm talking
about I'm done I can see the point I'm
too drunk oh don't give up don't give up
never give up never surrender I am
surrendering there's no there's no
drunken baseball Roth finish this
[__] pitch swipe rap for murder I've
been in worse pitches in a a studio so
it makes you feel any better I've been
giving worse ones before so keep going
you guys keep interrupting me stop
talking okay swipe right for murder
Jessica Chastain is actually a serial
killer who is going after men on Tinder
who use it inappropriately to take women
home seven eight different times a day
and give them venial diseases so it's a
little bit of monster that you see in
there these guys do exist Michael B
Jordan plays the detective that is going
after her and goes undercover to go on
Tinder and stalk these women and bring
them home unbeknown to him they meet at
a bar separately find a connection and
maybe there's a little bit of sexual
chemistry there and they but the trouble
is is that she has been killing the very
type of man that she believes he is puts
her into an internal conflict eventually
things escal escalate she is faced with
a decision to kill him or not I don't
want to spoil anything wait did you pick
from the same cup twice cuz you got two
really good actors I don't know again
Roth steals from the plot of inside out
don't worry we're
good Joe the country is
Germany the time is sometime during
World War I have a
pretzel yes
sir two two you
Germany's first female SS officer played
by Kate
Hudson runs a training center for the
best and the brightest SS
officers
meanwhile a man brought in to keep up
morale in the camp by running a quiz
show played by Alex
tbec
uh he's there uh he's
secretly
Jewish and uh he's doing this to survive
he realizes that uh him and Kate Hudson
have a love
connection they have one hot passion at
night she gets pregnant she finds out
that he's Jewish and they start she
should have found out when they got took
his pants off but thank you Mark andreco
Dr why are we drinking why are we
drinking why are we drinking was that
that's made a new rule every time Mark
andreco was Mark
andreco get your life alert bracelets
ready folks out
there guys it's quiz show meet Saving
Private Ryan
meets that Seth Rogan movie where she's
pregnant and he has to step up and be a
father Knocked Up Knocked Up what's it
called drink cuz I forgot a
movie it's baby Blitz Creek baby oh my
god wow
wow okay the floor is open fight I mean
come on is there really a fight here
time after slime it's adorable who
doesn't want to watch Nancy Grace turn
into the some of your love if someone
can pull that off if someone can pull
that off that's Nancy Grace has to pull
that off she's the actress she's not the
character she's going to do it it's all
been an acto she's a really nice person
she so she's Andy Kaufman yeah she's
been Andy caufman no for whole life I've
legit not seen you this drunk since your
birthday this is her chance to finally
show her true colors true
colors at the end Peter Dinklage hear me
out Cindy loers true colors I see a
that's enough Peter dink wait wait wait
Peter Dinklage and Nancy gra slowly
coaching on each other they're about to
make out true colors shine they can look
at each other I see your true color
looking they get the spark in that's why
I love you and he just
T and that was the worst Jack Black
impression I've ever seen in my life
that's love guys quiz show meets Saving
Private Ryan meets knocked up there's a
little bit of Comedy there's Oscar
Prestige it's a period war movie how
easily guys with acting jobs like Kate
Hudson who is a ROM she is a romcom
veteran you guys and Alex TRC has the
dry wit of
a whatever that one Comics name is
that's super dry and witty drink gu he
really forgets a lot it's a good catch I
just forgot what my rule was and I want
you to get
drunker guys this is about bur this is
about a charismatic quiz show host and a
horribly racist woman who's pregnant
with this baby trying to just make their
way through the world and isn't that
life isn't that just you know the human
condition and that's what movie making
is when I was walking to the death camp
this morning I thought that same thing
right oh my yeah that and that's Mark
being oh my God we're all saying
something in this argument Life is
Beautiful ouch you're not a
dick wow he called me a dick earlier I
was just calling him out back go ahead R
I deserve that I was actually going to
support you with life as beautiful as
being a comedic war movie it is don't do
it it's not it's really already did it
there's also fantastic fil
place in Serbia that's a amazing Serbian
film that's like the most unfunny movie
ever a film made by serbians not a
Serbian movie good
God do not do not look up that movie do
trust me I'm so proud by the way to be a
part of the
last paraly on the poster wow that might
be the first time a Serbian films come
up on movie fights wow the last did you
finish sorry no she started Andy stop
being such a [__] I'm let I'm eat my
cof okay so she's uh White play from her
actually could be kind of cool but then
she didn't she didn't fully commit so
you got it got it take note for that so
I'm going to go after this quiz show war
movie comedy love what every genre in
the world's in there and Kate Hudson
come
on oh dude Kate hson comes from acting
[__] pedigree dude she's a
non-actor I I have her Fab fabula
sweatshirt dress and it is is not only a
veteran of the quiz show he is truth and
he's playing a quiz show host in this
movie yeah that's not very exciting my
character also movie he's a proven
comedic want to see Nancy Grace finally
reveal that she's not Nancy Grace she
already did that Andy I don't want to
pay money to go see that the L Alex tbec
is an actual Vortex of Comedy like I
have no idea what you just said to be
fair just said Dallas tbec is a
vortex Alex TRC Alex and his wife Alex
both that is where jokes go to die
sadest drunk
fight Alex tbec is the least funny
person on the planet that is true
absolute fallacy in your argument I have
to say no he's the straight man the idea
that
veteran Kate Hudson can you deny that
Kate Hudson has been in a [__] ton of
romcoms she she knows what she's doing
P's gold this is this is beginning to
feel like the saddest bachelor party
Orange County Acapulco ever I like the
idea Nancy Grace is Andy Koffman okay
final arguments but she's not she's just
a piece of [__] we already knew that I
don't want to pay money to go see that
what I will pay money to go see is a
World War II movie SL quiz show movie
where two people fall in love overcome
their differences defeat racism and live
happily ever after raising their child
okay Roth final words I will say that my
movie is truly the only one that
actually makes any sense and has a
through line and has a beginning and
middle and end M actually
matches that could work and that isn't
completely outside of the realm of
reality where Nancy Grace is anything
but the Slime she could never be after
the Slime hey Mel Gibson's new movie is
getting great reviews and he's pretty
slimy too so yeah but she is what she is
and if she's in a movie she she should
only be playing Nancy Grace okay there's
so many dots up there and he also had an
animal um those mushrooms were for after
the show uh what's my movie called time
after slime it's did you tell Mark about
when you sang from a rose he's just
trying to sh time for slime is a
delightful title it has Peter Dinklage
and Nancy Grace showing her true colors
they k yes they love each other it shows
that anyone can find love okay all right
he just repeated my pitch
okay so the this this Peter de nany
Grace
movie I could almost see it being made
because Jerry Springer had a movie made
at one point ring Master y yeah so so
that's not you know that's not without
without that's not within the realm of
impossibility and I've had
four and I actually and uh not not not
to show favoritism but I came up with a
a tagline for your poster oh yeah it's
her in profile and him in profile And
the tagline is sometimes Size Doesn't
Matter oh that's cute C that's not going
to S my vote though let meish me finish
Mark I'd love to hear the taglines from
the other contestants I think they
should have a chance to PCH agre let
them pitch the tag I want Mark's tagline
on with she'll report any Grime on the
hotline I need I want to hear someone
come with the tagline for baby Blitz
green
the the the tagline for baby Blitz cre
is she did not see that
coming swipe swipe right from Swip right
from um sad lonely
people but a swipe right for murder is
actually a title that I could see
someone like Paramount that was the kind
of movie Paramount made in the 80s
sounds real AG Christie it it does if
she was alive and if she wasn't spinning
in her grave over the fact that we would
call something Agatha Christie swipe
right from murder uh and it reminded me
of Sea of Love I don't know if you
remember the movie that put Alan Barkin
on the main stage with with John Goodman
and alpacino back when he still cared um
and you got and of of these movies you
have the of these movies you have the
best two actors so I think you might
have drawn from the traditional because
you got Jessica Chastain and Michael B
Jordan we think maybe that's what
happened yeah but but that's okay that's
okay okay hey that's okay smart move and
Kate Hudson is an SS officer if she gets
to design her own fabletics s uniforms
that could be really cool which she does
but but but is there what is Alex tbec
doing is there like death camp Bingo
what is he's literally hosting like Nazi
officer Jeopardy he's like he's like the
Uso he's a Uso act but it's SSO yeah
he's SSO okay he's he's Captain America
yeah it sounds a lot like that Jerry
Lewis movie the clown that CED or Life
is Beautiful which is one of the most
sought-after films to see in the [__]
world saw a stage reading of it Pat and
Oswalt did them years ago and I saw a
stage reading the entire script I don't
think we ever need to see the movie The
Stills are enough but then you brought
up Life is Beautiful which in my mind is
the worst did she did she she did but he
embraced it he embraced it he embraced
it I didn't embrace it he embraced it it
was like it was like Chris Christie
embracing trump it wasn't real but it
was sincere
UG and life is beautiful is is notorious
because Roberto benini who went on to
make nothing beat outo like I said
nothing went on to win the Oscar for
best actor over Ian McKellen in Gods and
Monsters which which is which is
absolutely a travesty so ultimately it
comes down to he's making a mockery of
you right now it's fine it's only fair
take a moment no no I'm good I'm good
I'm good I'm taking my job seriously
unlike him when he Judes
me I'm being me I got a drink I you got
a
drink um I hope any anyone watching this
is having as much fun as we're temped
having F so excited to be a part of the
movie fight so this one comes down
between Roth and Andy and ultimately it
comes down to that every time it comes
down to Roth and Andy yep Roth didn't
talk well you you had Kate Hudson so you
ultimately I drew it from a mug Mark and
Draco fate is not kind some people are
born gra I made it work did you but but
that's that's where the downfall comes
ultimately cast in a movie called swipe
right for murder cheated into the PO of
M was
accident she she's barely coherent she
didn't cheat on purpose so Andy's
arguing with the judge that's a
drink oh it's the first time that
happened wow that's impressive good for
me so I got to say the movie that I
would like to actually kind of see that
I I've been drinking from a cup that was
also full of potato chips and I just
realized it this whole show when you
just give this to Roth does that count
he's arguing with the judge too I'll
drink that's ridiculous Mark and Draco
so who wins Ross Ross this go to Roth
yeah that's not
[Music]
okay questions more oh I didn't I didn't
go to I didn't go to the Spencer Camp
not too many fact checks except he's
drunk too I saw that I'm not that drunk
Nancy Grace Nancy Grace was in Batman v
Superman so she has a long acting
pedigree yeah it's all an act I wish I
could have remembered the name of that
film and Miss Missy pile did a great job
playing her and Gone Girl God that was
incredible all right
okay Roth well done no it wasn't did you
win that yeah she got it well done I
literally conceded the point halfway
through a win a win's a win nobody
remembers how much you won by it's just
a win or a loss the win okay the next
question is and this I didn't write this
one what two actors who have never done
a sex scene together would share the
most memorable sex scene and let me give
you a little little blog to this one
when I saw read that question actors to
me is a gender neutral term so I thought
people were going to say Angelina Joe
Lee and
Chan the first round of the answers for
this are almost all man-on-man action
and I'm not a and I'm not a contestant
so it's beautiful and we are going to
start this round with the winner of the
previous round Miss Roth
okay the movie with Tilda Swinton and
Jonathan Reese Meyers who you guys oh
good there is you guys might know best
from Titus andronicus just kidding from
the tutors okay so the name of the movie
is transition they are Intergalactic sex
assassins working for rival political
factions they are assigned to kill each
other and their species can switch
gender at will the reason that they can
switch gender at will is because there
was a time previously in their history
the one gender was too elevated in the
population no one really remembers which
one it was at this point so the downside
of their particular nature is that they
can go into overload with their pleasure
centers and die and so they are sent to
kill each other from sex so they have a
sex scene in which they are switching
genders every few minutes inside the sex
scene in order to try and overload the
pleasure centers and to send each other
into a series of orgasms that will
ultimately kill them so sometimes it's
two men sometimes it's two women
sometimes it's a man and a woman they
switch all the time I don't want to
spoil it with you
wins top that
[__] wow sorry IFC is on the phone
they want to buy that
now Joe follow up the intergalactic sex
assassins who [__] them to explode oh
you want me to follow up a sex scene so
boring she had to give it a weird plot
wow
I
will first of all let me say I'm the
only person here that didn't change
their answer 17 times today and this was
my answer before I knew Mark andreco was
judging that's not true I don't know why
I said that Mark liar
yeah I'm good you okay you good I'm good
is this a tactic some water is this a
shitty Andy move I'm good I'm good I
love you so much please continue Joe's
turning into me it's so
cute
oh my god look what I've created it's
like Russ it's like Russian nesting
dolls maybe the nicest thing that's
anyone's ever said to me um you had a
hard life huh you're smart guy smart guy
okay interior downtown apartment do we
know who the stars are yet you're about
to
okay Kurt Russell with his Tombstone
mustache he did this on purpose he knows
how I feel about him and Big Trouble in
Little China tank top are you saying
that this would make this the most
memorable r no I'm not Kurt Russell
taking a bath claw foot antique bathtub
claw
foot I can visualize that that's really
descriptive income bubble bath or no
strategic bubbles we don't want to blow
our
w we do though it's a sex scene few
enough
bubbles to see the big trouble tank top
logo you know you do that fan service
cuz that strategic bubbles by the way is
my second choice for a drag
name
can Mark and I just have a screen
junkies plush show where we just say
weird [__] no all right you were doing
that's how pies to Andy go no no
enter Henry
caval home from work so boring beautiful
suit already sweating it's summer oh
yeah it's hot out he's already
glistening a little
bit
he comes in and he says I didn't know
you already home Kurt Russell says with
his Tombstone mustache I
am get in this tub you
Curr Henry
cavl without removing any of his clothes
oh gets in the
tub
yeah starts to kiss is Kurt Russell who
again just to cement it has his
Tombstone mustache there goes Middle
America yeah can I argue though I
haven't even gone yet [__] you I'm
setting the scene these R these rounds
slow down a lot good thing I did that
first one in 35 seconds cuz we're going
to Long Mark if you do not if you break
eye contact with me while I finish
pitching this this is [__]
rigged hey
sweetie get out of here all right let
let them have this moment
BR Henry caval gets in the tub sploosh
we get some water over the tub it leaves
they kiss it's slow it's tender they
take their time these are two
experienced
men Henry caval soaked expensive suit
pressing against his
body slow Pan the oil from his hair just
soaking into Kurt Russell's
mustache it's kind of gross but okay
these are two these are not these are
two men who know every inch of each
other how many inches
exactly which
one I wouldn't say no to either but but
[Laughter]
Superman in inches not not not not
metrics that's that British thing I
don't I don't know what that me no sure
that's fine just under seven um it's
okay but it's not about the size is it
Mark no just like the Peter movie
Sometimes Size Doesn't Matter exactly Jo
there you are with Kurt this is a this
is a
scene it looks like senior class
pictures where you're like in profile
behind yourself amazing this is a scene
about one of the greatest actors of all
time having his way with a beautiful
piece of meat who then Cooks fakes eggs
with him after
climax this this is Kurt Russell and
Henry C markco that was the most
pandering [__] I've ever heard about
right all right you got to hear mine out
ready all right so don't show my photo
yet this is a real love story all
right all right better have a tub in it
stars Brad Pit as a celebrity he's
afraid of coming out of the closet oh he
just broke up with Angela and Jolie this
is this is really Brad Pit playing Brad
Pit he really wants to be with men and
so he lo and behold he he finds this he
finds this guy he finds this guy he
really he admires he's a comic book
writer named
Mark it's played by Shan tum let's look
at the
photo Shan T is
there I look like shanning tum when he's
not filming when he doesn't have the
trainer when he's like [__] it I'm going
to drink beer and eat stick this this
amazing wonderful proud gay comic book
writer a
park I'm taking points away from you at
this point he's just trying to make you
know make a living and there's Brad Pit
who wants to have his first time right
and so this is an important moment
because there's a lot of closeting in
Hollywood this isn't funny this is
really for real so this let's get to
this moment because you know Mark as a
gay man knows there's a lot of that in
this town we got it it's hard it's hard
for big celebrities to come out and be
out and proud my just advise me against
right so but I mean Kudo is this man for
doing it this is a story just like you
it's just it's completely I didn't even
think think of the parallels mark That's
how drunk we are he believes I have a
publicist I didn't the parallels are in
Cy I just I was just spilling cuz I
wanted to tell a good story but anyway
the parallels are crazy but Mark here he
is finally Brad is like I want it's that
you're just spilling now but Mark
spilled for my pitch so there's Brad and
Mark and they're together he's like I
want you to be my first but I know this
is a big deal but this is not it's not
just me there's so many of us in in in
this town who don't get to come out and
so here we have this moment where're
finally he talks Mark into to making
love to him and he's surrounded by all
these men
look Ronnie Gosling Chris Hemsworth Oh
Come the [__]
off I want that to be the new screen
junkies t-shirt Brian they are welcoming
him into this community and say it's
okay for you to love it's okay to love
and Mark and Brad Pit makes Sweet Love
in front of the assess
man it's called The Power of
Love it's called bring a mop hey Mark do
you want a story about a guy who um just
uses Mark andreco for sex but yes I do
refuses to come out publicly if I get
approval on who pay that part absolutely
I've been saying this for years you want
a story about two men who know what they
want who know what who know how to
please each other let me let me tell you
where you went wrong Joe okay tell me
Roth I'm going to tell you exactly where
you went
wrong before Henry caval got in the tub
because I was paying attention he was
wearing his clothes he was wearing his
clothes you not take his clothes off
that man is a God that man is an Adonis
why off all of his clothes he was
thinking did you see the scene from
Batman versus Superman the extended
ultimate cut when he's the nak it in
that no but he takes his shirt off and
his jeans are wet and it ain't too bad
is it want to be reincarnated as those
genes I think you might as well is it
fair to say that you remember that scene
Mark that it's pretty [__] meor
imprinted on my DNA let me let me ask
you this Mark would you rather see that
or would you rather see Henry cavl
slowly
disrobe present himself to his love
you're still describing My Scene Ro this
is working perfectly do it and that's
why it doesn't work is this how Hugh
Hefner feels we are talking about slowly
disrobed oh but mine has slow disrobing
too R you can't fight this I know how
obsessed with Ladi and gentlemen this is
why we need a Democratic president this
these conversations will not happen
under a trump regime Mark come here let
me oh
no this is
unfair Jo go now it's getting really
weird final arguments final arguments
you've all painted you've all painted
visual pictures Joe takes himself out of
the running for failing to get him naked
the end forever period okay
I'm sorry but yours just got so insanely
convoluted I didn't even know what was
happening at the end we were talking
about the most memorable sex scene ever
Jonathan Reese Meyers is possibly the
this is him in sex he's the weirdest
sexiest guy ever you look at him and
you're like I don't know what it is I'm
probably going to Reg regret it but I
want to get on it right now there's
nothing L sexy be memorable than having
to describe how sexy a man is no and the
two we are fighting for the most
memorable sexy in a movie ever the fact
is that this movie includes a sex scene
which has two people taking every
possible position in sex ever created
together at once wait I didn't get to
have a final argument nor did I but you
had an extra visual so it all balances
out I didn't get a final
AR you you want you know she talks about
this we're going to get naked right away
my scene is about two
men they each know what their partner
want
wants and the importance of everything
this is not
about give me right hers is like that
Simpsons porn I don't
remember memorable I don't remember who
she was arguing I
don't this is the
most and Henry yellow having sex with
each other I feel like Judge Judy shut
up wait I do want to say his last
sentence shut up shut up
okay wow this was quite possibly the
weird thing I've ever been a part of um
can we show can we show my final image
again not in a bad way but it's
weird you know you want to see that is
going to be the Gay Pride La poster for
2017 nothing hotter than shitty
Photoshop I should have been working
instead of making that but I made that
oh nothing says gay pride like shitty
Photoshop so did you just try to seduce
Mark andreco with Ms paint you son of a
[__] phot he's classier than that okay
I'm going to start with Andy yes Andy's
moving
with watch I would but I don't think
it's actually a movie I think it's
actually pornography I think it's a I
think it's like a men.com XX parody
thing while it might be enjoyable it
lacks narrative
heft and you accuse him of pandering
with Henry Caville and then you name a
character who [__] Brad Pit after me
so the publicity still love Mark that I
photosh the rules should be the rules
for everyone so if that's pandering
yours is really pandering
um yours was great I I I never thought I
would hear a Titus reference on movie
fights which is a crazy Julie tamore
movie on based on the Shakespeare play
which is the Shakespeare equivalent of
Friday the 13th it's an insane movie
with Anthony Hopkins Jonathan rice Meers
uh Jessica Lang it's a great movie um so
got you got points for that Julie Tamar
at our best yeah well we'll leave it at
that um Intergalactic sex assassins I
think says it all that that that that
sums up the movie and when you said they
genders and you flash back and forth I
thought of sense8 the the wowski sister
show which is that's so but then you had
Henry Caville damn it but he did wasn't
naked just just you know you had you had
the Strategic bubbles which were you
know as a comic book writer who
sometimes writes suggestive scenes you
have to be strategic with the props so
realistic so strategic bubbles works the
claw foot tub I I was see sort of like a
deadwood Westworld gay porn Vibe going
on um the age difference between C and
Henry is a little less than the age
difference between Henry and myself so
that gives me hope um you use the word
CER points for the word CER anytime
someone talks like Conan but he was
dressed I mean at the start of the scene
yeah but you never you never once even
when he got in the tub you never once
said he unbuttoned his shirt revealing
his Brad descri sex she just described
the plot of a movie get you with those
wet jeans though hadry I brought up the
wet jeans yeah but you remember that
scene but not because of him because of
the ultimate edition was trying to mimic
that's where I was taking you no so so
one question how was your movie shot is
it is it oh he's still thinking I love
this how is my movie shot is it is it is
it 3D is it 70 mm is it is like porn is
it one of those vibrating seats that you
pay $35 for yeah oh my God I have all of
the options in the world okay um it is
shot
by lki it is shot by lubeski it is
incredibly hot but artistic I would
reference back a little bit to bound not
to steal from you but yes that is
somewhat of the style it is 70 mm there
is no 3D version I'm sorry it's not 3D
it's going to you wow wow wow for no 3D
holy didn't see that coming yours was so
weird and so cool if you had said 3D
that would have pushed it right over the
edge well that's not 311 wow so the fans
gave that to Brad Pit and chanting Tatum
which means Joe's got to take a shot
take a shot wait a minute so that means
we're 31 and one it's a tie between Joe
and Roth to see who goes into the final
round with Andy I need a speed question
what do we do now uh give one speed
round question to see who goes into the
uh you you should have extras down here
uh do I get to pick which extra yeah
these are your five speed round
questions me it should be extras you
need five speed one or two number one or
two um Let's do let's do number one okay
so we're doing the 20 seconds and then
10c rebuttal cor and will you guys call
you hear a ding when the time ready you
have to Hollywood's best Dave or David
what name it Dave or David Hollywood's
best Dave or David actors yeah hurry up
what or any David you could be a
director um is there anybody else well
this one flops so let's move on on no
the judge said let's move on really I
know this is all the move on can we do
another question three yeah you have it
in your face they don't the first the
first two Time Records don't look at the
bottom okay okay you have TI all right
best speech in a
movie don't drink and drive kids wow no
it's so drunk it's so drunk right
now I see the thing is there's the the
speech speech you guys name someone who
talked in a movieovie
someone DAV who talked in a movie this
guy is not going to go for it but I
don't [__] care go for it it is deep
blue sea it is Sam Jackson I don't
care
Jo all right five it's the freedom spe
and Braveheart okay all right there we
go congratulations we have a fight Ross
go ahead the Sam Jackson speech in deep
blue sea is so freaking underrated yes
it is a comedic moment I saw this movie
in a packed theater in Harlem where in
the middle of she got New York give her
more time I'm adding a few seconds but
keep going I saw this movie in at pack
theater in Harlem where when the moment
happened when the shark came out and bit
him and brought him down the whole world
knew that every speech that came before
was just Vol [__] Miss Clinton your
time is up Clinton Hillary hangs back
this is a speech that redefined a genre
people refer to speeches in movies like
this as a Braveheart speech it's been
parodied which is the most sincere form
of flattery they may take our lives they
may never take our freedom hers is not
about the speech it's about the
punchline it's about the shark this is
Mel Gibson at his top form and you're
talking about the movie that takes down
every speech like this movie that takes
itself too seriously that is selfs
serious that doesn't understand that it
is [__] in the end because that
never happened final thoughts
Joe begins when he starts to
speaking let him
go this is an a an award caliber speech
by an award caliber actor hers is is a
fine speech that relies on the punchline
you removed the shark which has nothing
to do with the speech you repeated
yourself you repeated yourself because
it's the only point I need to
win hey tough huh this is tough because
I have I got him to do it oh oh I'm
taking a point away from him now we have
to drink again cuz that was me being me
oh [__]
[__] I need more pineapple juice um by
the way I gave people the fingers so I
got New York so I am not a fan of the
movie Braveheart I am not a fan at all
that's fair it's about I enjoy deep blue
SE trying to get my apple juice he's
still alive ladies and gentlemen these
high these chers are high sir and you
both gave very very passionate arguments
um but ultimately it came down to a very
specific thing that you even
acknowledged the speech in deep blue sea
is not about the speech it's about the
moment of this pretentious let's all
fight let's go save Private Ryan it's
about the jump scare of the shark that's
what makes it memorable and even though
I find Braveheart to be one of the worst
films to ever win best picture the
speech in that movie is the center point
of that movie
so by the most ra razor thin of margins
is going to Mr joar I'll take
wow right no no no come here you guys
going to have sex I love you too it was
it was as close as could possibly be it
was as close as could possibly be I can
not win to two more worthy opponents I'm
super
drunk no one can name it Dave I am so
glad I did not have to argue David Hy
Pierce David Letterman
oh I like all the r was Dave
Frank it was I couldn't do it it's three
to one you guys do you have anything
contribute any facts any information for
Joe he's like his favor I think way
let's just crash this train uh it's 3 to
one Andy oh it's on fire it's crashed
already there's a couple people that are
that going to be rescued but they're
probably going to
die they all stopped watching right
happy 2ye anniversary to two years high
fives y we did it
we ended it we killed drun movie fights
we killed movie fights Mark and Draco
Jesus Christ okay The Bargain Bin so oh
I got to walk up there sh two movies two
DVDs are going to pop up on the screen
you gentlemen me Joe
Joe win you know I [__] up here ready
pull up the
visual oh [__] Supergirl vers Howard the
Duck Howard the Duck I said Howard the
Duck you you questioned you see I said
it Howard the Duck that you were
verifying what the movie was I Howard
tough to tell um I I would say that you
said it like is that Howard the Duck not
I guess I'm choosing Howard the
Duck I whatever I was like Howard the
Duck Ken
Ken was my intent I'm try we did not
have
inflection question so I guess
technically you I was confused cuz I'm
like those both suck okay ready oh so I
gotta go first yeah oh [__] all right
here's what I got to do Howard the Duck
Right duck boobs I mean that was a
lifechanging moments people as a kid you
see boobs on a duck and you just go
that's possible this is a real thing I
mean how can
you how can you deny that Supergirl
doesn't have anything like that duck
burps made so many children just
questioned everything which is so great
for the rights of
animals somebody make a duck boobs GIF
right now what are you talking and your
wife's making you sleep on the couch
when you get
home okay
Joe the only thing Howard the Duck has
going sorry sorry yeah go
ahead the weird thing is that was manual
I don't understand how that happened uh
the only thing Howard the Duck has for
it is how shitty it is and if I want to
watch a shitty movie I'll just watch the
room it's it it's succeeds in that goal
better Supergirl is easily the third
best Superman movie which ain't bad
after super Man 1 and Superman 2 I'll
give it that caliber Howard the Duck
there are better shitty things to watch
Supergirl is at least the third best of
a super franchise hold on do we do they
get final thoughts on this one yeah I
get out 10 seconds but it's when I spoke
hold on a second
okay is it weird that I I own both of
those not at all what's better shitty
than the guy from Ferris buer who's
awful and a duck that's a human all the
crazy [__] that goes down Supergirl is
an awful movie you even said it it's the
third best I'd much rather watch the
only the duck adaption that we can get
that has duck boobs that's the shittiest
weird you
get the third best Superman movie is
still pretty [__] good after Quest
for Peace if I want to watch a shitty
movie I'll watch Quest for Peace Howard
the Duck does not succeed in the shitty
movie genre and that's the only thing it
has going for it
Supergirl wow wow now you can use them
for
help fan on the couch Danny what do you
think um have you seen both both of
these awful movies I've seen Howard the
Duck but not super ah he saw the duck
boobs I did see the duck boobs and I'm
kind of did it move when you saw
him disappointed that uh Joe didn't
bring up the fact that there was
incest or beastiality not inest yeah he
didn't so I have to go with Andy okay
I'm sorry I'm not just going to [__]
judge people for what they're
into well we're going to have to drink
on this because this one is legitimately
T
sorry and believe me I don't want to
drink anymore um duck boobs yeah duck
that
movie that movie if you had done that I
just would have quit yeah if you had
sung dunk Bo duck boobs to the Thomas
Dolby Howard the Duck theme which I
owned on the 12 in remix of
it okay um but ironic so but ironically
both of these movies the duck boobs and
Howard the
Duck and f d away and Supergirl I think
both helped make me gay so but for
entirely different reasons um based on
the arguments based on the arguments
based on the arguments uh well actually
based on the arguments if you had
brought up Thomas Dolby I still own the
Howard the Duck soundtrack on vinyl
because the Thomas Dolby song is
actually a big fun stupid song to dance
your ass off to but legitimately
Supergirl probably is you forgot the Cav
one but Supergirl is actually Supergirl
in that era Supergirl is aged really
well and that that ultimately was the
once again this is choosing fair enough
so the point goes to
Joe so it's two to talking about those
duck boobs though we all remember it it
was a thing duck boobs woo if you just
sung a Ducktails parody about duck boobs
I would have just quit my job okay I
would have gone back to temping you won
that hard what are we going up to do we
if if if first five Spencer is sober
first of five what first first of five
okay so Andy is a three Joe is a two
question number two for the speed round
is your very first favorite movie as a
child who Big Trouble in Little
China he's so goddamn
young I remember the original Birth of a
Nation there are pictures of me as a kid
with your favorite movie is a kid the
first movie you thought was your first
favorite old Ken your first favorite
movie as a s being uh ET okay wow Joe
are word with the clock Spencer
ready Big Trouble in Little China is
[__] brilliant it's Kurt Russell as
this action star who is terrible at his
job and all of his supporting actors
have to step up to save him he's a
beautiful idiot savant it's an
incredible performance in an incredible
world uh David Lan is one of the most
memorable fun villains ET is is fine but
it's it's Steven Spielberg
standard the originator of Steven SP
standard and it was an amazing children
family every film your film is
horrifying for a child that's a very
weird Choice ET is horrifying in
actually a way I was scared of ET but it
in a real sort of way of like there's
aliens in the world and all these sort
of bigger ideas of and and acceptance of
things it's a much better children's
film and it's a much better film
Spielberg's best you even said
it I said it was fine it's not best uh
big Trum in Little China is one of John
Carpenter's best films and this is a guy
who who is [__] working to change
film big Trum in Little China subverted
tropes it's so
fun Reese's Pieces man I ate so many of
those as a kid look at me that clearly
shaped to I am that was an amazing kids
movie mic
drop oh wow
wow okay ET is one of I would say the
top five movies St Spielberg made but
there were a bunch of points you didn't
make in your argument other than c candy
and you went right to Candy Andy don't
don't [__] give me what points it
Candy Andy um Al Al although I am not a
big fan of Big Trouble in Little China I
I there are movies that like the
original Clash of the Titans and things
like that that when you see them as a 10
or 11y old you can be amazed and those
are a gateway drug to other good genre
films going to ask them huh um I I
haven't decided yet I haven't decided
yet I'm giving my opinion then we'll
consult with the the Hoy pooy on the
couch I like when you just said the
Beatles are good band judge I ARG with
the judge oh yes you argue with the
[Applause]
judge I'm never doing this show again
boyu um you brought up some you brought
up some points about Big Trouble in
Little China That's seen Through The
Eyes of a 10 or an
11-year-old elevated the film so this
becomes a challenge because ET is one of
my favorite films of all time so so as
you jump to the gun I am going to
consult with Spencer and our guest Danny
on the couch that was tough uh man I
don't necessarily agree with what Joe
was saying and I did appreciate Andy's
uh candy Andy's rebuttal but his about
merch but his his opening argument was
word soup I didn't quite understand what
he was saying just a lot of positive
words in no particular order so I got to
go with Joe okay I'm also going with
Joe yeah right Joe I no you're not
the you're not the judge tonight got
check with ro no
yeah she does no I don't she was
dreaming about up JT no I actually was
dreaming about drinking oh nice awesome
so uh although I do think ET ultimately
is the better movie this is based on the
arguments and Joe gave the better
arguments so the point goes to
Joe so we're tied up three to three
there are very problematic pictures of
as a little kid with a laundry basket on
my head be a three stormm shut up shut
upen long problematic pictures of you as
a child is a series of
minutes3 minutes Joe [__] what how long
is this supposed to be
like oh really really we're 45 minutes
long yeah it's fine just keep right next
question you have to watch the same
movie four times in a row what movie do
you
Redemption Star Wars A New Hope
can you finish the question though that
was it you four times in one four times
in a row which do you
pick you were firsts so tell me why
about shank we've seen both those movies
so many times but I want to watch the
movie that's going to inspire me and and
challenge me and Inspire and tell me
give me drama comedy uh Thriller shash
shank is so nuanced in such an amazing
film with such amazing performance is it
surprises every turn the things you find
in there the journey you go
on finding new things every time you
revisit that Star Wars that is the thing
that launched a genre that is the thing
that launched a phandom Star Wars you
can watch every day it's a part of your
[__] DNA it's like visiting an old
friend it's like a family reunion but
with family that you actually give a
[__] about and want to be around shash
Shank Redemption whatever power
converter is the most annoying character
in the world I don't want to watch that
over and over again I've seen it a
billion times already enough and we see
it every time they bring it back sha
shank is a definitive classic I would
argue a better film The only time you
can watch shash Shank Redemption is with
commercial breaks on TBS and commercial
breaks [__] up a movie Mark andreco
everyone owns Star Wars on Blu-ray
everyone owns Star Wars on DVD or VHS I
own that [__] on
Blu-ray wow this was the straightest
question ever um sha Shank Redemption
versus Star Wars and this is about the
arguments um sha shank you brought up a
lot of good points it's a movie that has
connect that has connected with a lot of
people on uh a a lot of levels I myself
have problems with the differences from
the movie and the story um I think it's
a well-made film but for me I I like I
prefer the story much better that
there's a substantial difference at the
end Star Wars of course is a movie that
you can either love or hate for what
it's done to the movie situation in the
world now with Studios only making $300
million movies based on things uh but
Star Wars did change the face of film
making but your argument was that it was
just better than this there weren't a
lot of specific I said it shut yeah you
said that you said that once but you
didn't go back and revisit it was just
sort of once I had 20 seconds Mark and
Draco I had the same time Joe star he he
you said less no he actually he actually
said more and I like this movie less
than I like Star Wars but his arguments
based on the rules of the game his rule
Andy gets the point so it's four to five
so this Show's still going so this is
this is the Schindler's last episode
also Comm are great for movies and TBS
is great for movies shut okay uh this
one if Andy gets it he wins if you get
it you tie and we have one final
question what movie character not actor
what movie character smells the
best I thought this was an easy question
myself
Patrick baitman American Psycho
[Laughter]
Jesus now we need you have the
confidence to go first Joe now you're
trying to change your answer go ahead
Joe change it take your time it's not a
96 minute long show five 4 3 2
1 what do you got Ray Star Wars force
awakens this girl has been stuck in the
desert for
ages it starts when he starts talking
we'll start over 3 two 1 go this girl's
been stuck in the desert for ages I
don't want to smell her she's a
wonderful lady but my God they don't
have showers and wherever she's from
Patrick bman has money do you see that
how much money you spent on that
business card can you imagine how much
he spent on his cologne that man is
going to smell Beautiful he's coming to
murder you he wants to entice you he
wants to bring you in that guy you want
to get right in his armpit and just
smell the
beautiful have you ever been in an Uber
with a guy wearing too much cologne [__]
that [__] that a body spray layered
[__] seconds Joe gets the
point
wow we've been here for 4 days and I'm
drunk Joe gets the [__] point
cool let's do our tiebreaker all right
okay a sh oh I shouldn't stand but let's
do it you know what can I skip ahead to
the tiebreaker one question last
question tiebreaker question what movie
character do you definitely not want as
your Uber driver home Patrick
baitman
oh
it's over Dude wash Serenity I don't
even know who that is he just said it
Patrick B's going smell the worst of the
X my friend's going to murder you when
you get home
done wash is going to [__] die at the
end of this Uber trip and that's going
to be in your brain forever I'd rather
smell a weird dude than watch someone
spear through the heart 10 seconds
you're just stopping the time I'm just
stopping it this is gone on long enough
I I mean I can't I don't even know who
this guy is i that's not even close he's
a serial killer and he smells like Axe
Body Spray that is the worst combination
of manal dor you can possibly Pi up
[__] you love this guy how do you not
know a famous Jos Weeden character you
fake nerd he dies in front of you holy
[__] that's horrifying who who who is he
he's out tunic in
Firefly Andy
wins
oh wow see see this is what a fair and
impartial judge looks like God that was
so I am a leaf on the Wind all right I'm
Andy sigar on
Twitter I'm sorry this took so long
folks I just broke this there's a
pretzel there all right I'm Andy sner on
Twitter thanks for watching oh before we
go my new comic book is out Min series
The Death of Hawkman it's a Min from DC
with amazing art by Aaron lepry
featuring the character Adam Strange
please if you don't hate me already
please go buy it please go buy it
awesome and thank you for humoring me as
a judge Ro coret
joar no no thank you for letting judge
Spencer on the couch Danny Our Guest
Danny how was that thanks brother
awesome I'm so glad it that was
something we'll talk about it after the
fight I'm taking over bye everybody see
you next week
every podcast we put on YouTube comes
with this Kick-Ass graphic listing all
the topics your favorite screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast Battle Royale go
ahead try them all if you haven't
already subscribe to screen junkies on
YouTube to join us for future fights or
if you prefer to listen on iTunes click
the logo to download an audio
version